hey guys how's it going before this
video started I was gonna act like you
guys weren't here you know but that'd be
stupid because you know I turned on the
camera so obviously I would know but as
you guys saw from a previous video I
told you guys that my parents came to
visit me in k-town and it was it was a
really good experience now one thing
that you guys are gonna find out about
me and my parents is that we have a you
know relatively good relationship I
think that when it comes to most Asian
kids and the relationships they have
with their parents it's very it's very
emotionally in the sense of the majority
of your guys conversation with your
parents is did you get go great you do
good school
then you'll finish homework 5 but not or
not but of course when you have a very
close relationship with your parents you
just might find out things about
yourself that you never wanted to know
very clearly you got your doors shut
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
dig up can I do a project you two had an
arm turn I'm a nun
who you are then yogi little biology
show baby shower tonight
oh yeah baby are you awesome your job
double high adults as hormones don't
hire Joe Scheffer even guys you go toyou
don't you are the pink oh yes yes the
thing about like Asian medicine there's
no science behind that [ __ ] it's always
just hey put the bean sprout on the
ground if it were left you were boring
maybe when my mum Shinedown maybe it's a
girl but I could doctor on time what
about so an agreement dodging janavarta
Cara you're a paralegal problems out of
the budget
he'll come to England a pellicle to it
on the deck a better fit for them yeah
going oh you okay
Hey or a Koreas case you know the
berries of the lobe then he Sakura is
around the bar but yeah man I think I
develop a more closer and more personal
relationship with my parents when I
started growing up because I started
seeing them as people and not my parents
now what I mean why that is not in the
sense that you know I don't see them as
mom and dad anymore it's more like mom
and dad are people too
they want to develop a relationship with
me and this kind of sense because as we
get older
we start to relate a little bit more
than that because you know when you're a
kid you can't just you can't really
relate to adult subject but you know now
that I'm in my upper 20s I can I can
relate to my dad more especially when it
comes to crazy women Muriel
just kidding baby I love you oh look I
get by are always a fundable ah yeah
dancing good all my butt chin Jeff isn't
our normal obesity critical no meeting
emoji hey uh you're gonna talk about the
car [ __ ] or Monaco Sun god I'm gonna do
quantum come on you gonna hey cheetah
the winter of Canada fine little talk
very little and Canada what no that'll
take two - okay hello little more time
on Tesla tables oh thank you but being
able to empathize with your parents and
even more so than that actually
communicate with them really opens up
your relationship if I can give you guys
any type of advice out there for you to
get along with your parents take the
step back one time and just realize that
your parents are people not just mom and
dad but they are people though it may be
hard for you to realize this now because
it was hard for me because I felt like
they never understood me I think that
they do understand this because at a
certain point they were our age and they
went through similar emotions so when
you eventually do come to that
understanding just watch and I guarantee
things will get a little better
I see here
it's got a mani